a bead artist drills a tiny hole from
the top corner of a cube bead to the
opposite bottom corner of that bead it's
a cube bead each ed
edge of the bead is one half centimeters
how long is the hole that she drilled so
if i'm interpreting this properly let me
draw that cube bead which i will just
draw as a cube a big cube here
nicer cubes have been drawn in the
history of cube drawing but i'll try my
best
so let's see
this is my best shot at a freehand cube
i think that does the job
reasonably well we could even if this
cube was transparent you could even
imagine kind of that back side over
there and the base of the cube if this
was a transparent cube they tell us that
each edge of this cube bead right they
call this a cube bead each edge of the
cube bead is one half centimeter so this
is one half centimeters this is one half
centimeters and that is one half
centimeters and then they say that they
drill the hole from the top corner of a
cube bead to the opposite bottom corner
of the beads from the top corner to the
opposite bottom so i think they're
talking about the longest diagonal that
can fit in the cube going from the back
right top corner over here to the front
left bottom corner right over there
that's the longest diagonal it could fit
so let me draw that so it would look
something like this this is the distance
in question how long is the hole that
she drilled that is the distance that we
have to figure out let's see how we can
think about that and this is a bit of a
classic in terms of figuring out a
distance the longest diagonal of a cube
or some type of rectangular prism and
the trick here is to see that this is
the hypotenuse of a triangle the
triangle isn't completely obvious to you
just yet and to think about this as the
hypotenuse of a right triangle what you
have to do is visualize
the diagonal of the bottom face of this
cube think about this diagonal right
here that i'm drawing so the diagonal of
the bottom face of this cube if you
think of it that way then also we have a
right triangle that's kind of going
across this cube this is a right angle
over here so if we could figure out we
know we know what this length is this is
one half centimeters if we could figure
out the length of this orange side right
here this part that's going
diagonally across the base of the cube
then we could use the pythagorean
theorem to figure out what the what the
distance in question is this longest
diagonal of the cube
now to figure out this orin side you
just have to visualize the base of this
cube let me look let's look at this base
just if we're just in the cube looking
straight down at the base it would look
something like this
you'd have this side let me color code
them it'll make it easier to visualize i
think you have this side right here
which i will do in this blue color so
i'll draw it over here you have this
side in that blue color and then you
have this side over here which i'll do
in the magenta color
you have this side over there in the
magenta color they are both of length
one half so i'll draw them of roughly
the same length
and then you have this orange side that
goes across to the bottom of the base of
the cube
and i'll do it as the same
orange dotted line right there
just like that let me extend this side a
little bit
and we know this is a right angle this
is a cube we're dealing with so there's
a right angle we know that this side is
one half centimeter we know that this
side right over here is one half
centimeter so if we wanted to figure out
this diagonal or this length right here
we can just use the pythagorean theorem
we know that one-half squared
if we call this i don't know if we call
this right here x
we know that x squared the hypotenuse
squared is equal to the squares the sum
of the squares of these two guys is
equal to one-half
squared plus one half
squared
or if we want to solve 4x we could say x
is equal to the square root
the square root what's this going to be
the square root of 1 4 that's one-half
squared plus one-half squared which is
one-fourth
or what's one-fourth plus one-fourth so
x is equal to the square root
of one-fourth plus one-fourth that's
two-fourths or one-half or you could
write that as 1 over
the square root of 2. now we could
rationalize this but i'll leave it like
that for now it'll keep things simple so
this distance right here is 1 over the
square root of 2 or we could say this
distance right over here is 1 over the
square root of 2. so if we were to draw
the right triangle where the hypotenuse
is the length of that whole let me draw
that right triangle so
we have our hypotenuse
which is this long thing over here let
me just draw it like this
that long thing over there
we have this side over here in yellow
this side right here
we have that side right there it is of
length one half centimeters and then we
have the side we just figured out this
side right here that x side
this right over here
right over here this side over here is a
right angle we just figured out this
length it is one over the square root of
two centimeters one over
the square root of two now to figure out
the length of the hole we can apply the
pythagorean theorem again
if we have this is let me say
h
h for whole length of whole actually
even better let's say l
l for length then we can say that l
squared
l squared is going to be equal to 1 over
the square root of 2 squared 1 over the
square root of 2
squared we're just applying the
pythagorean theorem
plus
1 squared plus 1 squared
and once again we know that this is the
longest side it's opposite the right
angle so it's going to be the sum of the
squares of the other two sides and so
that's going to be equal to so we get
l squared
is equal to what's one over the square
root of two squared
well one squared is one over square root
of two squared is two and then you're
going to have plus one half squared
one half squared is plus
one fourth so l squared is equal to
one-half plus one-fourth one-half plus
one-fourth is what let's do it over here
one-half we can write it as two-fourths
plus one-fourth is equal to
three-fourths so this right here is
equal to three-fourths
so we have l squared
l squared i change the shades of green
just there is equal to
three over four so l is equal to the
square root of three over four so we
take the square root of both sides you
get l is equal to the square root of
three over the square root of four
what's the square root of four the
square root of four is two
and we're done the length of the hole
that was drilled in this bead from this
corner over here all the way over here
is the square root
of 3 over 2
centimeters because everything we've
been dealing with has been centimeters